we've tried the chicken factory I'm
still having nightmares about this
giblet we try beautician turns out hot
wax is not my friend I'm running out of
options for you here Luiza please I'll
take anything this is New York air and
companionship for disabled man do you
have any experience of caregiving um
I've never done it but I'm sure I could
learn then that's gonna be well well
this is music lock Nathan we'll talk you
through wills routines and equipment you
don't have to talk across me mother
my brain isn't paralyzed yeah he hates
me every time I speak he looks to me
like I'm stupid to be fair you are
pretty stupid yeah but he doesn't know
that yeah interesting choice of footwear
what do you mean by that I can't be from
around here why not this is the kind of
place people come to and they got tired
of actually living I'm happy here and
well you shouldn't be any get one life
thanks for your duty to live it as fully
as possible
no stay tell me something good when I
was little I a favorite outfit was my
bumblebee choice
bumblebee sorry black and yellow stripes
a pig [ __ ] you ever loved anything that
much
yes loving can hurt this then Tommy
after why bro pretty either one can I
take you somewhere you are so going on a
date with will trainers too baby get the
red dress out we keep
I don't wanna go in yet I just might be
a man who's been to a concert the girl
in red dress a few men tomorrow
loving can heal I promised my parents
six months that's what I've given it but
that was before me I wanted to live but
only if he wants to live
I can't just let this happen you can't
change your people huh
I mean what kind of meat of it you love
them and I don't want you to miss all
the things that someone else could give
you
thank you
I have become a whole new person because
to be there's something clogged you are
pretty much here anything that makes me
want to get up in the morning wait for
me to come home ms opus yet madoski
vanilla vanilla de la vie so lamas
Calcifer visitors Vida House cookie jar